after seven straight weeks of losses u.s
stock indexes ended one of the worst
sell-offs in history the s p 500 had its
worst 100 days to start a year since
1970 and the nasdaq had its worst first
100 days ever in the history of the
index while some are betting that the
worst is over i'm going to tell you why
there could be more selling to come
we'll break down how this sell-off
compares to past downturns provide some
insight on where things stand for the
u.s economy and detail why things are
likely uphill from here
let's get into it
there have been comparisons between this
sell-off and the dot-com bubble burst if
2022 is anything like those days there's
a lot further down to go
from the peak of the bubble in 2000 to
its trough in 2002 the nasdaq fell 78
at its lowest during this downturn the
nasdaq had fallen 32 from its most
recent high
further companies like tesla gamestop
and other tech favorites are still
showing incredibly high valuations
gamestop has a market cap of 10.5
billion dollars that's larger than
household appliance juggernaut whirlpool
and hyatt hotels tesla still has a
market cap of nearly 800 billion dollars
making it worth more than every other
car company in america combined
even though it sells less than five
percent of all cars in america so what's
the current state of the u.s economy
while the market downturn we've seen has
been significant businesses are holding
up well u.s corporate bankruptcies were
the lowest they've been during the first
quarter and at least 20 years
and the percentage of businesses that
are delinquent on their loans remains
historically low consumers are also
healthy according to credit agency
transunion which described american
consumers credit recently as strong
retail sales bank deposits and other
measures of consumer spending have also
held steady or increased so far in 2022
that all suggests the stock market's
losses have done limited damage to the
real economy that's a good thing but it
also means the stock market is unlikely
to get much help from the federal
reserve
in the near term the fed has only raised
u.s interest rates twice from nearly
zero percent
and when factoring in inflation rates
are still negative so throughout all the
turmoil in markets the fed had been
providing accommodative monetary policy
that's about to change
starting in june the fed will begin
what's known as quantitative tightening
meaning that rather than pumping money
into the economy they're sucking it out
and minutes from the fed's latest
meeting show the central bank is
considering moving towards restrictive
policy levels meaning raising interest
rates high enough that they restrict
economic growth that's something the u.s
hasn't seen in a generation and it could
put more pressure on stock prices but on
the bright side markets are
forward-looking so this may have already
been factored in and there's a chance
that the worst is behind us but there
are certainly some bumps up ahead
the legendary big daddy kane told us all
in 1992 i gotta take control of my own
destiny control what i hold and of
course be the boss of myself
no one else will bring my wealth
that's all for now i'll see you next
time
you